[Musik]
fahrzeuge kommen meine damen und herren
zur viertel nach acht der dauer
meinungsfindung im deutschen tv nächsten
55 minuten werden die über migration
markus söder und maßnahmen sprechen ich
freue mich sehr über meine heutigen
gäste führten nach acht
wiederholungstäter stammgast und ich
weiß sie sehen sie sich jetzt den
zuschauer vor allem der chefredakteur
der weltwoche roger köppel kein gast
wurde in der zuschauer vor so ersehnt
wie er neben der ressortleiter
feuilleton der welt und welt am sonntag
andreas rosenfelder er 2008 auch das
buch digitale paradiese von der
schrecklichen schönheit der
computerspiele veröffentlicht hat und
dass wir heute auch über das ipad an
meiner seite der
cdu-bundestagsabgeordnete und kult
politiker philipp anton lars bender
links bild moderatorin patricia plat sie
bestimmt von unserer morgendlichen
sendung bild live kennen mein name ist
nähmaschinen und ich freue mich heute
ihre gastgeberin sein zu dürfen das
konzept der sendung ist sehr einfach
jeder von uns hat zehn minuten sendezeit
für ein thema das sind beschäftigt
ärgert oder freut den anfang machen wir
heute selbstverständlich mit roche wir
blicken in die ukraine ja liebe leser
ganz herzlichen dank für diese
fulminante begrüßung unter diesen
erwartungen kann ich jetzt natürlich nur
noch zusammenbrechen ich bin als
schweizerische friedensengel nach berlin
gekommen im zeichen der friedlichen
koexistenz und des zeichens an meinem
rüber er und ich ärgere mich über die
geschichtsfreunde
berichterstattung unserer medien über
diese tragischen verhältnisse in der
ukraine geschichte schreiben und setzt
die finger wund über die russen über den
fürchterlichen angeblichen teufel punkte
ihn aber das wichtigste thema wird
überhaupt nicht angesprochen und da sind
die kolossalen fehler die dummheiten die
überheblichkeit auch die demütigungen
die der westen gegenüber russland
gemacht hat und das finde ich echt
tragisch wir haben hier eine chance
verpasst nach dem kalten krieg als die
kommunisten weggefegt waren die russen
in die freiheit entlassen wurden und das
interesse hatte mit dem westen
zusammenzuarbeiten und was machen wir
nato osterweiterung in die ehemaligen
von der sowjetunion von russland wirtin
sicherheitsgürtel zonen warschauer pakt
da ist die nato hinein marschiert das
war ein tragischer fehler und das sage
nicht ich war mir hat die sowieso nicht
aber das hat kein geringerer gesagt als
george f kennen eine der legendärsten
diplomaten der us history ein architekt
der sogenannten eindämmungspolitik
während des kalten kriegs und der schon
in den 90er jahren die nato
osterweiterung auf tragischen fehler
bezeichnet als unnötige demütigung und
aus den beginn eines kalten kriegs und
die quittung haben wir jetzt dann kam
putin vieles vorwerfen man soll immer
etwas vorwerfen trierer schweizers in
dem es gibt ist bei großmächten aber
hier muss man auch mal über die fehler
die schwächen und die strategische
dummheit des westens sprechen und jetzt
philipp amthor bin ich natürlich
gespannt ja auch die fulminante
gegenthese hier im saures verbreitet
sich schon sibirische ja genäht dass
sich aber auch an der stelle finde ich
völlig angebracht denn man muss schon
mal sagen so sehr wir ja oft auch
auffassungen teilen finde ich ist diese
these die vielleicht so in einem
historiker seminar kann man darüber mal
sinnieren wie war das hat man sich den
90ern richtig verhalten in der aktuellen
lage wo putin die panzer auf die ukraine
räumen lässt die panzer in richtung
tierfreunden lässt sieht das natürlich
aus wie geschichtsklitterung und im
prinzip ist diese argumentation ja nur
eine rechtfertigung die putin im moment
auch für sein völkerrechtswidrige
agieren sucht und man muss man sagen wir
haben eine regelbasierte internationale
ordnung und da kann es nicht danach
gehen dass sich irgendwer jetzt schlecht
behandelt fühlt und putin sagt naja in
den 90ern da hat man jetzt das große
russische reich nicht so respektvoll
behandelt wie es vielleicht angemessen
wäre aus seiner sicht das kann keine
rechtfertigung für das jetzige agierend
sein und deswegen finde ich man kann
über die these reden aber andererseits
darf es jetzt nicht so genutzt werden
wie putin und seine schergen das wollen
nämlich als rechtfertigung für ihr
agieren in der ukraine
und da muss man auch sagen es von
russischer seite sehr sehr viel
geschichtsklitterung dabei denn diese
vermeintliche these dass sich die nato
nicht in richtung osten hätte erweitern
können das war eben völkerrechtlich
nicht bestandteil der regelung die im
zuge des wiedervereinigungs prozesses
und der auflösung des warschauer pakts
getroffen wurden und deswegen finde ich
man kann darüber abstrakt reden da hat
die these vielleicht sozusagen aus einer
empathischen bemühungen gegenüber den
russen hat das vielleicht irgendwie
wasser bei einer aktuellen lage finde
ich sie die pflanzen müssen dagegen
glauben sie wirklich dass das an der
heutigen situation irgendwas geändert
was wir gesehen haben ist doch dass wir
alle die skrupellosigkeit von putin
unterschätzt haben also wenn man diese
these weiterverfolgt glauben sie
ernsthaft dass er heute da sitzen würde
und sagen würde wir haben so eine
wahnsinnig gute partnerschaft mit den
westen da habe ich jetzt auch so viele
hände geschüttelt so viel vertrauen
aufgebaut das würde ich natürlich nicht
zerstören wäre noch das gegenteil jetzt
gelernt offensichtlich habe ich mich
noch zu wenig deutlich ausgedrückt auch
in einem schreiben das baby meine these
ist dass der westen die verantwortung
trägt für diese eskalation das ist doch
putin ist der kreis müsste jetzt wurde
ein bisschen da die luft rauslassen aus
dieser empörung jetzt müsst ihr ganz
kurz zu hören ich meine dass die
vorstellung dass der west
ukraine
hoffnungen machen kann auf einen ort
arbeitet auf einen eu weit ich meine wie
geschichts präsent ist das was würden
die amerikaner machen wenn die chinesen
ein militärbündnis schließen wollte mit
den mexikanern was haben die amerikaner
gemacht als die sowjetunion atomraketen
auf kuba stationieren wollten natürlich
ist das ich sag mal aus einer
humanistischen perspektive stoßen aber
es ist eine realpolitische tatsache dass
großmächte
interessensphären haben pufferzonen und
der westen hat das fahrlässig und
leichtsinnig missachtet und wenn wir
westen sich nicht so weit vor gedrängt
und ich zitiere dort in georgia kennen
ich zitiere nicht irgendeinen deutschen
und einem russischen politiker sondern
einen der wesentlichen und angesehensten
diplomaten der usa dann müssen wir uns
im westen die frage stellen was haben es
kann ja egal wie groß matic der diplomat
mal war jeder kann irren nur einen
einzigen jetzt als grund sei das aber
ein bisschen weh tun die struktur und
meine ist doch interessant dass ich weiß
nicht ob sie dort auch schon geboren war
zwar ein fahrschein da habe ich die
zusammenhänge die junge
frau
anfang der 2000er jahre da war ich schon
gewonnen haben
waren wir vereint nach die argumente
nicht besser ja jetzt kommt da diese das
deutsche überheblichkeit oder nein die
jungen es kommt ja schon die schweizer
not karten
vor 20 jahren hat putin im bundestag
eine rede gehalten hatte mir zu sagen
das ist ja eigentlich interessant als
freund des westens und heute sehen wir
einen ganz anderen putin das gegenteil
dessen was wir damals gesehen haben und
jetzt kann man schon sagen alles der
fehler der russen der fürchterliche
charakter dieses putin zeigt sich jetzt
bin ich zu sich ich würde mir die frage
stellen das ist auch die aufgabe die wir
hier haben was haben wir für fehler
gemacht um diese chance zu verpassen
einer strategischen partnerschaft mit
russland bin ich unterstreiche hier die
russen die wollen nicht mit den chinesen
zusammengehen die russen sehen sich nach
anerkennung durch den westen die sehen
sich als westliche christliche macht
aber wenn du glaubst eine großmacht im
moment ihrer schwäche nach dem kalten
krieg auf die art und weise demütigen zu
können wie das gemacht wurde dann hat
man aus der geschichte nichts gelernt
weil das darf man nicht machen das hat
immer tragische konsequenzen und der
westen hat lieber philipp an tor die
schwäche russlands in den 90er jahren
sträflich ausgenutzt anstatt immer mit
dem finger nach die russen zu zeigen
müssen wir doch auch mal selbstkritisch
uns die frage stellen was haben wir
falsch gemacht und da seid ihr einfach
zu unkritisch aber in der jetzigen
aktuellen situation stehe doch außer
frage dass putin ihr völlig egal ist wie
die völkerrechtliche lage ist dass er
hier jetzt klar die regeln bricht und
selbst seine eigenen emotionen und sein
wo russland sich schlecht behandelt
fühlen sozusagen als
rechtfertigungsgrund nicht und ich
glaube so kann es nicht funktionieren
das kann kein land der welt für sich in
anspruch nehmen nur dass man irgendwie
aus verletzter eitelkeit heraus glaubt
man könne einfach die territorialen
grenzen der länder beliebig ziehen das
kann ich richtig sein und ich meine die
rede von putin 2001 hier im deutschen
bundestag der wirklich sehr
beeindruckend weil die es eigentlich an
beispiel dafür dass wir russland
durchaus der die hand gereicht haben für
dialog und ich finde es ist nicht
unbedingt demütigung wenn man jemanden
wie putin im bundestag hat sprechen
lassen dann kann man jetzt auch drüber
lange reden wie das verhältnis von
gerhard schröder dazu putin ist und war
das ist alles thema für sich aber
andererseits muss man sagen ich glaube
die brücken wurden gebaut aber wir haben
natürlich ein immer weiteres
radikalisieren gesehen mit der situation
in der krim mit der situation auf dem
majdan mit der hybriden kriegsführung
und da kann man viel über strategische
partnerschaft reden was wir erleben ist
dass russland mit seinen
nachrichtendiensten permanent uns und
unsere bündnispartner angreift dass man
gezielt desinformationskampagne fährt
und dass am ende putin vor allem auf
seine eigenen interessen schauen also
ich habe kürzlich mit dem klaus von
dohnanyi ein großes interview gemacht
das habt ihr in der welt auch gemacht
und ich habe also gestaunt wie nüchtern
und wie ich finde realpolitisch
vernünftig diese zweige der
sozialdemokratie darüber gesprochen hat
und er hat etwas gesagt was ich 100
prozent unterschreiben würde der westen
hat kein interesse an einem
strategischen konflikt mit russland das
stimmt es ist richtig dass nach unserer
wahrnehmung verletzungen des
völkerrechts eine no-go-area sind aber
da bin ich anderer meinung als zufällig
da müssen wir uns selber an der nase
nehmen wir haben russland auch
radikalisiert durch diese
nato-osterweiterung aber jetzt sind wir
konfrontiert mit der situation wollen
wir tatsächlich einen krieg machen mit
russland aufgrund der ukraine und man
darf noch daran erinnern sie sind auch
in weißrussland das dauert dann auch
schon truppen da wird nicht weggehen was
ist das interesse russlands und das
interesse russlands ist es eine
pufferzone herzustellen wo sie sagen
hier möchte ich die nato nicht drin
haben um meine hoffnung ist jetzt
einfach die dass man nicht deswegen
irgendeine dummheit eine weitere
dummheit des westens macht nur die
nächste strategische herausforderung
kommt dann wenn diese sicherheitsgurt
gesichertes für putin dann ist dann das
baltikum dort haben wir ja russische
minderheiten in verschiedenen staaten
und da muss dann die nato zeigen dass
sie gegenwehr leisten kann und
vielleicht und das ist meine hoffnung
führt jetzt diese realpolitische
kälteschock russlands dazu dass die nato
wieder geboren wie etwa mit dem was wir
jetzt die bundeswehr die da haben ein
paar schicken kann das ist gar keine
richtigen auto mir aber einen krieg mit
russland oder einen strategischen super
konflikt der die russen dann noch in
chinesischen armee treibt das ist nicht
in unserem interesse und leider sehe ich
dass die amerikaner leider auch viele
deutsche journalisten in diese richtung
argumentieren ich meine deutschland
müsste sich hier nach wie vor wie das
schon gar nicht so schlecht gemacht hat
als ausgleichende zusammen mit makro auf
verständigung und frieden
konzentrierte macht beweisen die
amerikaner ein anderes
thema und soja gegen hauser und ersatz
an einem sechs meter langen tische irre
viel gebracht dieses gespräch zur
verstärkung aber ich sage einfach
friedliche koexistenz wir haben kein
interesse daran an diesem krieg weil die
leidtragenden auch in deutschland werden
die bürger seien nicht
so
vorsichtig wollte über die folgen der
russlandkrise möchte heute abend
versprechen ja es ist erst mal richtig
dass wir über eine russland krise
sprechen und nicht zuallererst mal über
die ukraine krise denn russland ist der
aggressor das muss man hier auch noch
mal unterstreichen und wir müssen für
uns jetzt klar machen welche folgen kann
dieser weiter anschwellende konflikt
haben unsere polnischen nachbarn rechnen
derzeit damit dass ungefähr eine million
migranten aus der ukraine nach polen
kommen könnten im ernstfall
und sie sind darauf vorbereitet sie
haben mit einem hilfsprogramm für die
ukraine derzeit vorkehrungen dafür
getroffen
erstaufnahmeeinrichtungen vorzubereiten
sie reden darüber wie man arbeitsvisa
vereinfachen kann für die ukraine und
ich finde es ist jetzt an der höchste
zeit dass auch die bundesregierung für
den ernstfall vorbereitungen trifft ganz
klar wir wollen keinen krieg das wort
reden wir wollen die humanitäre
katastrophe in der ukraine vermeiden
aber wir müssen uns schon jetzt auch
vorbereiten dass die gebetsmühlenartige
satz 2015 dürfe sich nicht wiederholen
migrations politisch auch in diesem
zusammenhang gilt wir dürfen nicht
unvorbereitet sein sondern die
innenministerin ist in der pflicht
zusammen mit ihren europäischen nachbarn
jetzt darüber zu reden wie wir auch eine
humanitäre katastrophe beantworten
könnten und dazu gehört ist das auch das
themenfeld der migrationspolitik noch
mehr in den blick fällt kommt das sehe
ich im moment bei der ampel in keiner
weiß es ist in keiner weise würden
machst du das fest wenn sie fehler hat
sich dazu geäußert hat gesagt sie ist
wachsam sie sieht dass man ist auch im
austausch mit polen was sind die
konkreten forderungen als wo sich ihre
punkte
das problem ist glaube ich auf den
kündigt das ist jedem klar dass es zu
einer katastrophe kommen könnte vor
allem wenn der ernstfall eintritt denen
wir uns alle nicht ausmalen wollen aber
was genau sind die konkreten forderung
also ich sehe das ganz praktisch ich war
dieser tage in meinem wahlkreis in
mecklenburg vorpommern unterwegs und
wenn ich mich dann unterhalte mit den
landräten wenn ich mich mit denen
unterhalten die eine solche kommunale
krise dann ja auch vor ort schultern
müssten migrationspolitische da ist
nichts vorbereitet und ich habe die
große sorge und das ist auch etwas was
viele vor ort im moment spüren
wiederholt sich so etwas wie man es 2015
erlebt hat ich kommentiere da seien
wenig gibt es dann den anruf jetzt in 24
stunden müsst ihr euch um das thema der
migration kümmern das kann nicht richtig
sein und vor allem müssen wir glaube ich
auch darüber reden wie wir jetzt diese
situation und auch den migrationsdruck
aus der ukraine so auflösen das ist
nicht allein zu lassen der ukraine geht
denn wir sehen dass jeder flieger aus
kiew in richtung europa im moment
komplett voll ist das liegt daran weil
alle dies können dieses land verlassen
wollen und das kann auch nicht in
unserem interesse sein und ich habe von
der ampel da nichts gesehen von der
bundesministerin habe ich zuletzt gehört
dass über eine koalition der willigen
zur aufnahme der flüchtlinge aus afrika
diskutiert die frage wie viele willige
dabei waren hatte sich schnell
beantwortet und sie müsste den
schwerpunkt jetzt auf zivilschutz legen
sie müsste den schwerpunkt jetzt auf
migrationsbewegungen ausrichtung der
ukraine liegen und da hat sie bisher gar
nichts vorbereitet aber im parlament
redete keiner mit uns olaf scholz nach
große dienstreisen im parlament erklärt
er sich nicht um die innenministerin
auch nicht also mehr ein bezug auf der
länder oder das im moment überhaupt gar
nicht stark den eindruck habe ich und
ich glaube an vielen stellen ist es so
dass wir jetzt natürlich auf den best
case einfach nur hoffen wir hoffen
darauf dass sich dieser konflikt jetzt
militärisch entspannt und das ist
natürlich auch unser interesse wir haben
ja kein interesse an neuen
migrationswellen und wir haben auch kein
interesse daran jetzt dann in großen
brain brain auszulösen in richtung der
ukraine aber ich glaube zur wahrheit
gehört schon dass wir darüber noch viel
viel klarer reden müssen und dann gibt
es die großen diskussionen über corona
und anderes mehr mit den ländern darüber
diese frage redet keiner und wenn ich
sehe wie beschwerlich das auch alles war
wenn man es vor ort erlebt hat in folgen
von 2015
erstaufnahmeeinrichtungen und co da
glaube ich müssen wir beim thema lessons
learned noch mal ein ganzes stück weit
besser werden weil wir die negativ
erfahrung die man in solchen situationen
machen kann ja an vielen stellen schon
gemacht haben aber nun hat man am
afghanistan-konflikt gesehen dass gerade
der militärische rückzug des westens der
migrationsbewegung in gang gesetzt hat
das heißt dass das nicht als natur
geschehen sich einfach nur abspielt und
wir dann mit den folgen konfrontiert
sondern dass man doch immer unmittelbare
auch wirkt wie unser verhalten und
unsere militärische und strategische
positionierung in diesen konflikten auch
auswirkungen hat auf migration bewegung
müsste das nicht auch jetzt ein teil
auch der politischen diskussion sein das
ist ohne frage so und deswegen bin ich
auch sozusagen diskussion von von noch
einmal aufzugreifen und zu verlängern
auch der auffassung dass wir ganz klar
jetzt auch sagen können wir treten da
jetzt nicht den militärischen rollback
kann ich meine ich habe das mit
bundeswehrsoldaten aus mecklenburg
vorpommern die jetzt in litauen gerade
im rahmen der nato operation unterwegs
sind sehe ich das ja sehr sehr klar als
die vor zwei jahren das erste mal
darüber geredet haben das dann das
einsatzkontingent ansteht und selbst als
sie glück haben dafür da sah das noch
ganz anders aus als jetzt ist es eine
reale konfliktsituation und so bitter
das alles ist ich glaube wir müssen ja
auch die präsenz aufrechterhalten denn
in dem moment wenn wir als westen sagen
soll putin da tun was er tun will und
wir schauen einfach zu dann werden die
menschen in der ukraine mit den füßen
abstimmen und darüber entscheiden dass
jeder der sich in irgendeiner form aus
diesem land bewegen kann sich daraus
bewegt und das problem ist natürlich wir
haben jetzt im moment ja auch
aufenthaltsrechtlichen erhebliches
problem denn faktisch bild so im
völkerrecht gilt der vorrang
sozusagen der binnenflüchtlinge das
heißt die ukraine die jetzt sagen uns
droht der konflikt die haben hier gar
nicht ohne weiteres bleiberecht
diametral monatige perspektive und ich
will nicht dass jetzt sich alle auf den
weg machen nach europa und wir dann in
einigen monaten dastehen mit einem
problem wo wir wissen ja jetzt sind die
menschen zwar hier aber wir haben für
die aufenthaltsrechtliche gar keine
perspektive das müsste man vorher
überlegen was machen die polen richtig
das ist ein gutes stichwort die präsenz
vor ort wir haben ja auch bei uns haben
unseren chef report chefredakteur
stellvertretenden chefredakteur vor ort
immer für mich ist er immer noch in
erster linie ein ganz großartiger
reporter der ist uns jetzt zu bescheißen
wir möchten natürlich von paul wissen
wie die lage vor ort ist auch mit blick
natürlich auf die menschen mit wieviel
menschen kann deutschland den rechnen du
hast philips thema gerade mit gehört
poul wie ist die lage was würdest du
philipp entgegnen dreimal verbinden weil
ich deine frage auf dem ordentlich
verstanden hatten den eins kann ich
sagen ich bin sehr geschockt von eurer
diskussion die dort gerade geführt wird
auf der einen seite höre ich wie ihr
über die fehler die sie in den 90er
jahren gegeben hätte mit vladimir putin
und wie man mit ihm hätte umgehen müssen
sprechen auf der anderen seite spricht
er über die zukunft und die sagt ja was
machen wir nun mit den flüchtlingen ich
kann euch sagen
hinaus zu keine die hilfen freunde von
mir die nicht wissen was morgen
mit ihren freunden mit ihrer frau und
ihren kindern ist es ist eine situation
für die ukraine
komplett alleingelassenen ist von dieser
welt und
ich muss sagen ich bin schon wirklich
geschockt darüber wenn ich höre wie
roger köppel sagt ja wir wollen nicht in
diesen krieg natürlich wollen wir nicht
in diesen krieg aber wer denkt denn die
menschen hier vor ort an die ukraine
hier hinter mir das ist der donbass das
ist die ost ukraine und in wenigen
stunden könnten hier russische soldaten
vor der tür stehen und dann die tür
klopfen mich festnehmen
mich würden sie wieder frei lassen aber
meine freunde festnehmen weil sie zu pro
ukrainisch sind weil sie
aus der sicht des westens aus der sicht
russlands sozusagen ja das falsche getan
haben hier wird über kill ist über
todeslisten gesprochen über
menschen die dann festgenommen werden
der lager gesteckt werden das ist die
realität hier das ist das was gerade
passiert in der ukraine und
ich finde wir denken viel zu wenig daran
dass es den menschen hier geht ich habe
leider gerade sozusagen meine leitung
hier verloren versuche ich jetzt noch
mal zu erreichen hier direkt damit ihr
noch eine frage stellen könnte ich höre
euch momentan nicht auf dem morgen
mein gerade des autors paul ronzheimer
sagt ist es ja umso wichtiger sich die
frage zu stellen warum sind wir
überhaupt in so eine situation gekommen
punkte als und was können wir machen um
diese situation zu bereinigen wenn die
frage ist ja was der film vorher gesagt
hat wir sprechen jetzt schon von
flüchtlingen und ich sage wie kommen
flüchtlinge verhindern wie kann man das
leid verhindern indem man den konflikt
deeskaliert und die amerikaner hat
meines erachtens nicht das interesse
diesen konflikt jetzt absolut zu
deeskalieren aber wir in europa und ich
bin auch schweizer in europa wir haben
ein interesse daran diesen diesen
konflikt zu deeskalieren und das was
putin will der will ja auch keinen krieg
führen mit 150000 truppen kannst du
nicht einen riesigen stadt erhoben das
ist keine invasionsarmee aber man muss
immer aufpassen dass sie machen und der
putin ist natürlich ein ganz abgefeimte
straße hat ja auch schon verneinen weil
sie uns zum beispiel gesprochen also der
begriff ist ja nicht geholt sie haben
sie haben die polnischen geheimdienst
haben immer mal wieder ein anderes dort
umgebracht oder die worgen ja nicht
falsch aber der punkt ist okay jetzt
aber der punkt ist durch dr was wollen
die russen was ist das interesse der
russen wir müssen hier über die
interessen sprechen und die russen
möchte nicht dass die ukraine
weißrussland
dieser sicherheitsgürtel in die nato es
wäre hineingezogen wird ein spielball
wird und wenn der westen sich dazu
durchringen könnte mit putin an einem
tisch zu sitzen ist auch eine
beschreibung die eskalation unverschämte
putin will die grenzen der länder auf
dem europäischen kontinent verschiedenen
das ist seine interessenlage wenn wir
darüber reden was putin will was
russland will dann muss es doch ganz
klar sein den geht es doch nicht nur
irgendwie um eine pufferzone
demilitarisierung putin will zurück zu
den vorstellungen russlands als großes
sowjetisches reich r bilder seine
einfluss wären arbeitern und machen wir
uns nichts vor sein interesse ist und
das zeigt sich doch sehr deutlich wenn
man diese rede hört wir über die ukraine
spricht er will nicht nur irgendwie die
ukraine die militarisieren sondern er
spricht er das existenzrecht ab er will
sie in russischem hoheitsgebiet
hineinbringen und das kann ich in
unserem interesse sein so kann man nicht
mit internationalem recht und paul ist
jetzt wieder da die leighton müsste
widerstehen wir hoffen es auf jeden fall
ist ist ja immer palast uns wieder
wir hatten wie ich höre ich wieder ich
hoffe ihr habt das gehört was ich gerade
gesagt habe ich hatte euch nur auf dem
ohren nicht nur deswegen die
telefonleitung wollte stimmen wir haben
alles er gehört was du gesagt hast hast
du uns da jahren auf gott wirklich noch
etwas ja antworten sonst hätte findet am
tor auch noch eine frage an dich in die
ukraine
ja also erstmal herzliche grüße und
danke auch fürs fürs live
berichterstattung ich glaube das ist
ganz wichtig dass man in der tat den
blick jetzt darauf wirft wie es die
situation vor ort und die menschen
fragen sich in der tat nicht wie im
historiker seminar woran liegt deswegen
was ist die erwartung eigentlich der
menschen vor ort ich habe jetzt so ein
bisschen das thema migration zwar
mitgebracht für den worst case aber ich
glaube die allermeisten wollen doch in
der ukraine bleiben was wünscht man sich
da was es die botschaft aus der ost
ukraine die wir mitnehmen sollen ins
parlament
man wünscht sich eines frieden
und man weiß hier in der ost ukraine
woran das liegt dass es keinen frieden
gibt ich war heute an der front in einem
dorf bin dann als es beschuss gab
zusammen mit einer alten frau ludmilla
nach unten gegangen in diesem keller
und ich habe sie gefragt was glaubst du
woran liegt das was ist mit diesem
konflikt und sie hat gesagt putin macht
gerade einen großen fehler meine kinder
sind alle in russland
habe kein problem mit russland ich
verstehe nicht warum gesagt wird das ist
von der ukraine angeblich eine russland
feindlichkeit gebe und gleichzeitig
haben die leute den glauben völlig
verloren dass die deutsche politik die
europäische politik die us-politik
irgendetwas tun könnte um irgendjemanden
zu retten der in dieser nacht in den
nächsten stunden morgen übermorgen hier
angegriffen wird hier wo ich gerade
stehe daher glaubt niemand sanktionen
die hat putin eingepreist das was dort
gerade erklärt wird es lächerlich das
ist dass es längst gedealt worden all
die sanktionen sind viel zu schwach die
jetzt gerade passiert sind auch was
oligarchen angeht was diejenigen angeht
die mit putin zu tun haben ich glaube
deutschland hat noch nicht verstanden
was hier gerade passiert putin hat
dieses land umzingelt mit all den
truppen die er dort stehen hat
hunderttausende und all das was wir
hören ich habe gerade mit dem auto und
mit dem präsidenten selensky sprechen
können alle anzeichen deuten darauf hin
dass der angriff gegen die ukraine und
nicht in anführungszeichen nur und das
ist ja auch schon absurd gegen die ost
und keine sondern dass ein großer
angriff in den nächsten 48 stunden
passieren wird keiner glaubt daran dass
der westen irgendetwas tut und alle
sind verzweifelt
bei vielen herzlichen dank für deine
berichten wir werden auch morgen wieder
zu dir in die ukraine scheint mir bei
fiel nach 8 und dranbleiben dankeschön
für den einsatz vor ort
und damit machen wir eine ganz kurze
unterbrechung und sind gleich nach einer
ganz kurzen pause wieder für sie da mit
markus söder mit corona und mit
innenpolitischen themen bis gleich
also da kann ich dann ein lauter frauen
nicht ernst nehmen als sogenannten
experten
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren nachtleben traut der schlagzeilen
machen mein name ist wieder fit
so nicht privatjet buschi hergestellt
werden aber niemand von den politischen
parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur freiheit diese
grün-roten der damen führen hochtrabende
debatten über die rettung des weltklimas
und um die füße russland die ratten das
thema ist viel zu wichtig um es nur der
afg zu überlassen lasst den leuten noch
mal den spaß wir sehen da etwas was
eigentlich fatale ist in der politik bei
den journalisten deren job ist es doch
gerade eigene meinungen zu finden und
sie sollen den doch auch richtig gut
doch wir sind übrig anooraq träger aus
ich habe meine sache immer bekommen er
kümmert sich darum niemand ist die
wilderer man muss der ganz kleine auch
darüber sprechen dass rein sagt nicht
der hat nämlich richtig ist die komödie
nicht beklagen nur noch vierte lauf
[Musik]
wir sind zurück und ich darf mit meinem
thema heute abend starten das ist markus
söder wer diese sendung verfolgt bei
sich haben poltert er drei neue minister
ein neuer generalsekretär der
bayerischen ministerpräsidenten öffnet
den csu wahlkampf mit frischen
gesichtern ja angekündigt hatte markus
söder eine verfeinerung seines kabinetts
herausgekommen ist ein minister beben
bayern hat nun insgesamt drei neue
minister für mich zeigt dass austausch
puzzle ganz deutlich markus söder ist
getrieben vor angst die landtagswahl im
jahr 2023 verlieren so der spricht von
einer schicksalswahl doch auch mit dem
neuen köpfen wird ein hoher wahlerfolg
bei der landtagswahl doch hoffentlich
nicht gelingt denn die wichtigste
personalie die ausgetauscht gehört ist
doch populist markus söder selbst ich
hoffe dass die bayerischen bürger nicht
vergessen dass markus so dass corona
politik angerichtet hat menschen durfte
in münchen zeitweise nicht mehr alleine
auf einer parkbank sitzen sie wurden
gebeten aufzustehen im freien musste
maske getragen werden und von den
kindern möchte ich jetzt gerade gar
nicht erst anfangen gerne nennt sich so
das team vorsichtig nenne ihn lieber
team wählerstimmen das erklärt auch
warum man jetzt ja auf rechnungs kurs
ist markus söder gehört abgewählt
im sturm ist der analyse zu ich finde es
schön wenn
ich
hätte etwas vorsichtiger verteidigung
also ich finde tatsächlich auch dass
markus söder auf die unangenehmste art
und weise profiliert hatte
tatsächlich autoritäre politiker eines
formats das eigentlich in der
freiheitlichen demokratie
nicht richtig am platz ist ich würde
trotzdem einen punkt widersprechen ich
finde die tatsache dass er sozusagen
auch weiß aus rein pragmatischen in
treffen wenn kurs gewechselt hat macht
ihn sympathisch mir ist ein populist
jederzeit lieber als ein ideologe und
ich finde was man tatsächlich da was
erwähnen kann ist das für den kurs nicht
aus ideologischen gründen sondern
tatsächlich aus materialistisch
strategischen gründen gewechselt hat da
wäre ich grundsätzlich immer hoffnung
wenn leute überhaupt in der lage sind
auf stimmung zu reagieren deswegen ist
mein urteil jetzt nicht so vernichtend
bieberstein das macht einen guten
populist wenn aus
einem guten populisten macht es
tatsächlich aus die stimmung erst mal in
der bevölkerung wie man ja sagt volk
sagt man ja nicht mehr so gerne früher
hätte man gesagt die stimmung im volke
zu erspüren und
und sein politisches handeln danach
auszurichten auszurichten und das finde
ich grundsätzlich sehr richtig ich
glaube auch dass weder die stimmung in
der bevölkerung falsch eingeschätzt hat
in vieler hinsicht in der krise das hat
man gesehen dass seine popularitätswerte
blätter nach unten gegangen sind diese
autoritäre kurs des quasi corona
generals und des großen macher ist der
halt in der regel mit mit harten
verboten und mit mit harten ansagen auch
politik gemacht hat der hat ja nicht so
richtig funktioniert also insofern ist
da sicherlich noch nicht der perfekte
populist
also mittel mittelprächtiger populist
mittelprächtiger populisten merke ich
mir vor allem ich sage ich nicht mehr
pseudo popstar ich sage mittelprächtiger
populismus hört sie auch direkt besser
ich kann nur eine aus der distanz zu
haben erscheint und daher keine aber
keine aktien ich habe keine aktien in
bayern und alles als schweizer ist
natürlich der so zurückhaltend
zurückhaltend geben aber es muss ein
populist ein populist ist sie haben sich
ein politiker der immer das sagt was das
publikum gerade hören möchte und ist
eigentlich ein schlechter politiker ein
politisches oder gewisse grundsätze
haben und diese so de vertreten auch
unabhängig von der zusammensetzung
seines publikum so mein eindruck von
markus söder ist gab es ein hobby ist ja
ist verwandlungskünstler und diesen
karneval spektakeln dritte 100%
verkleidet als kiss gitarrist aus
schreien jetzt nicht auch noch
kritisiere und
das ist eine ich merke dir unter ist
übermotiviert
er hat so eine fähigkeit aus
verwandlungskünstler und ich glaube das
ist ein bisschen das problem von ihnen
das ist auch das was dich stört hier
wobei du voran natürlich mit der krone
politik von ihm wie gehabt aus und wenn
ich ihm von außen betrachten würde sagen
er ist so populistisch ist für mich zu
wenig csu-politiker war mit der csu habe
ich immer identifiziert einem franz
josef strauß so soft wurzeln die dann
bei ganz bestimmten themen unverrückbar
fels in der brandung war und wenn ich
mit leuten aus bayern spreche dann habe
ich viele kritik gehört auch an leute
die gesagt haben denn ist uns zu
wankelmütig heute umarmte die bäume
morgen steht er allein bei corona dann
ist er wieder der erste der den die
impfpflicht fordert dann wieder der
letzte der sie aufhebt und so weiter
also ich glaube das ist ein beispiel für
populismus im nicht guten sinne quasi
eben man sagt einfach das was das
publikum hören möchte populär das ist
gut wenn du natürlich populär bist aber
populismus da gibt es viele aber
meistens sind die die als populisten
bezeichnet werden das sind gar nicht die
populisten frau merkel war auch eine
populistin die hat auch oft jemand aus
wieder erzählt was das publikum erwies
dem philippe bozon ich auch gern ja ok
aber bis ihr euch entscheiden das ich
gelesen dank der präsidentin der
finanzen gewannen hören sowie hackl und
alle hatten
da haben wir es auch in dieser liste der
vorwürfe an
ich finde also ich muss bei allem sagen
ich finde er war jetzt zu anfang der
pandemie der beliebteste oder einer der
beliebtesten politiker und ich finde im
gegenteil ich war auch er wenn man sich
in teams eingeteilt vorsicht und ich
finde er hat das eben rüber gebracht mit
einer ruhe und eine entschlossenheit die
glaube ich bei ganz vielen für ruhe
gesorgt haben in den anfängen der
pandemie ich fand es entblößt dass er
nachdem er eine woche zuvor gesagt hat
er steht für die impfpflicht in mir
schon gesagt nein könnte schwierig
werden weil man muss sich vielleicht
irgendwie fünfmal boostern und wie wir
das eigentlich umsetzen und man sieht
schon irgendwie wackelt an allen ecken
nein an einer ist er wirklich dafür und
ich glaube eine woche nach diesem
gespräch so weil dabei also impfpflicht
für pflegekräfte machen wir jetzt leider
doch nicht nee also bin ich wirklich
dagegen da war es da dass ich so ein
moment mal sehen war hat für mich die
fassade nicht gebröckelt das macht das
gut und warum und alles was zusammen
gefallen ich das im moment mal also
dieses wortbruch war für mich auf dem
krieg und der zweite fehler glaube ich
den er gemacht das ist dass er nicht
während des wahlkampfs ich weiß jetzt
gegen ein bisschen zurück und weg von
corona aber dass er nicht einmal ehrlich
gesagt hat wisst ihr was ich sehe das
jetzt mit dem laschet ich wollte nie
sagen aber ich schmeiße zimmermann gut
ins rennen ich würde das machen ihr
wollt mich eh alle ich kann es besser
wollen wir nicht doch und ich glaube das
hätte zu einer glaubwürdigkeit
beigetragen ich weiß gar nicht wie es
dann letztendlich ausgegangen wäre aber
ich glaube die rolle zu spielen zu sagen
danke ich will dich ich habe schon
bayern sind sogar aber der macht
wirklich wahnsinnig schlecht hätte gegen
mich gefragt ich glaube das hat ihm
keinerlei sympathie punkte eingebracht
aber jetzt du
also wird zumindest mal eine these
aufgreifen wenn man sagt populäre
politiker muss man sagen natürlich hat
der markus söder kriegt jetzt viel druck
ab aber er ist nach wie vor enorm
beliebter ministerpräsident und hat hohe
zustimmungswerte und man muss vor allem
eins sagen jetzt kann man natürlich
sagen es gibt andere die sind da
vielleicht ein stück weit er
ideologischer um es in den worten zu
sagen aber ich habe markus söder immer
als unglaublich professionell
wahrgenommen und natürlich kann man
sagen ja klar der korrigiert jetzt
häufiger seine meinung als andere aber
ich finde er ist schon jemand der
durchaus auch im persönlichen in seiner
kommunikation dann super hohen grad an
professionalität hat und auch immer den
blick nach vorne da wirft auch was jetzt
die personalentscheidungen angeht weil
das war ja so ein bisschen der anlass
für die these heute na ja da hätte jetzt
eine kabinettsumbildung gemacht nein das
ist nicht so ich glaube das ist wirklich
ein gutes personalpaket gewesen zeigte
dass es weniger frauen dabei sind vor
fünf jahren hat er sich noch gefreut hat
ist cases halbe alter jetzt endlich
erwacht aber zwölf minister achso 3 in
frauen hockey hat er das ganze richtig
nach vorne also dankbar wenn man jetzt
sagt die kernthese dieser
kabinettsumbildung sei die herstellung
von parität im bayerischen kabinett ja
nicht den kern t ich glaube und hafen
verlieren schon ab ich glaube jedenfalls
dass in der entscheidung die vor allem
für berlin ja auch relevant dass die
frage generalsekretär hat eine sehr sehr
gute entscheidung getroffen mit meinem
kollegen stephan mayer der vorher
staatssekretär im innenministerium was
eine top- professionelle personalie
markus blume ist ein minister geworden
und ich war das schlecht gemacht hat als
generalsekretär da sehr erfolgreiche
arbeit gemacht hat und ich finde
jedenfalls aus der sicht sozusagen der
die kollegen da auch kennt ist es eine
sehr professionelle kabinettsumbildung
ich glaube deine kritik hakte auch er
daran dass du natürlich insgesamt der
korona politik nein reden ist in der
regel ja nee ich werde schon nicht mit
dem zukunftsteam das führungsteam habe
für mich auch waren immer irgendwann
habe oder aber jetzt holen wir neue
gewicht jetzt geht es los und ja
eigentlich den neuen gesichter ich kann
es gar nicht so schlechte wussten jetzt
george w
der junge
wurde mit dem besten ergebnis im
bundesvorstand gewählt und einer aus
diesem zukunftsteam ist jetzt partei und
fraktionsvorsitzende hendrik bertz und
finde ich eher stecken so schlecht war
dass es nicht unter diesen
zukunftsthemen doch der entschied der
welt vorraum aber irgend eine andere
frage worauf sich auch meine meinem ein
statement dazu dass er angst hat
übrigens auch beruft und zwar die die
werte waren jetzt auch nicht so gut für
die union in bayern oder wenn wenn du
sagst die zwischen- oder hat euch das
ergebnis in bayern so gefreut union also
zur wahrheit gehört natürlich dass wir
zu dem ziel der absoluten mehrheit was
man gebetsmühlenartig vorsicht richter
ist natürlich noch ein weiter weg aber
ich glaube der markus söder wird zur
landtagswahl schaffen da auch gut
abzuschneiden und natürlich konnte sich
ja auch niemanden koppeln auch vom
allgemeinen bundestrend auch in bayern
konnte man das nicht aber wenn alle
landesverbände der cdu so gut
abgeschnitten hätten wie die csu in
bayern wäre es glaube ich auch ein
besseres bundestagsergebnis kann muss
immer damit vergleichen was auch schon
früher mal möglich ist auch der anspruch
und wir arbeiten uns langsam in die
richtung wieder wo man meinen man mehr
sagen haltet wird suchen kämpft also 4
gegen einfach gut gemacht philipp und
jetzt gehen wir auch direkt an erkenne
ich mir bleibt wie der innenpolitik und
gehen jetzt weiter so andreas
rosenfelder ja ich möchte heute eine
partei kritisieren für das ganz gerne
heißt dass wir hier im hause springer
als netzwerk sind nämlich erst bröker
die fdp ich finde dass die fdp sich sehr
viel klarer sehr viel entschieden dafür
einsetzen dass wir in deutschland einen
echten freiheitstag bekommen ob der
extreme der heißt oder nicht ist mir
eigentlich relativ egal wo man sich im
ausland umschauen ein land nach dem
anderen die dominosteine fallen die ja
gerade passiert wirklich sämtliche
kroner beschränkung 1 in deutschland
dagegen nicht kanntest du panik aus weil
am 19 märz das ist fast ein monat hin
noch die korona maßnahmen auslaufen die
übrigens dann auch noch zu den
strengsten der welt gehören
die ampel koalition diskutiert gerade
allen ernstes über diesen sogenannten
basisschutz unter dem sich dann
maßnahmen von der masken pflicht über
die abstandsgebot bis hin zu 2g und 3g
verbergen sollen die auch weiterhin
möglich sein sollen dass es so ziemlich
genau die kurven erleben da sieht man
bei einem vorher-nachher-vergleich
wahrscheinlich gar keinen unterschied ob
man die fotos vom 18 und die fotos vom
22 wer vergleicht mir kommt das alles
ein bisschen vor wie disney channel
steht was man hier für meinen geschäften
sieht das steht ja immer darauf wie
mögen sie mit abstand am liebsten und
daran hat man sich irgendwie
eingerichtet habe ich das gefühl in
deutschland das klingt harmlos erst mal
abstand masken das ist aber sehr
gefährlich in den weg stellt und wenn
man diese maßnahmen einmal entkoppelt
von einer akuten notlage die längst
nicht mehr gegeben ist darüber herrscht
einigkeit es gibt keine akute
notsituation in krankenhäuser solche
maßnahmen rechtfertigen könnte dann
schafft man den neuen norm dann hat man
noch eine neue norm gesetzt und das darf
nicht passieren die fdp ist eine partei
die hat lässt es ja nicht auch das nicht
zuletzt deswegen so gut abgeschnitten
weil viele bürger vor allem auch viele
junge bürger das gefühl hatten dass die
vermutung für die freiheit
abgelöst worden ist in der pandemie
durch eine vermutung für die sicherheit
jetzt hat die fdp die freiheit im namen
das ist der erste buchstabe dieser
partei und trotzdem zögert sie sich klar
zu positionieren also ich nehme es
einzelne stimmen war aus der fraktion
und auch aus den ländern aber christian
lindner und marco buschmann halten sich
sehr vornehm zurück mit deutlichen
ansagen das am 19 märz auch wirklich
alle kokona maßnahmen fallen dabei wäre
es ihre aufgabe
darauf zu achten dass die einzige rote
linie die der rechtsstaat der
demokratische rechtsstaat wirklich kennt
respektiert wird nämlich das grundgesetz
die fdp muss jetzt zeigen warum sie
gewählt worden ist wofür sie gewählt
worden ist ich denke für faule
kompromisse braucht man keine fdp das
kann eine große koalition besser ja ich
meine das ist die ballade
der politik die man in allen ländern
betrachtet kann das halt der parteien im
wahlkampf
großartigen programm vertreten und ihre
ideale
preisen und kaum sitzt man dann auch
seinen bequemen ministersessel dann
verändert sich dann der mensch mit dem
vorteil und mit der angebeteten
ministerialen existenz und ich kann das
ich beobachtet also etwas distanz muss
sagen fast schon wieder bewundernswert
die komplexität und das wort chaos zu
vermeiden der der korona maßnahmen in
deutschland da kommt ja ich glaube da
kommt ja selbst herr lauterbach hat ja
völlig die übersicht verloren
deshalb kann ich
diese nur schwer jedoch freiheit kann
ich sehr gut nachempfinden da kann ich
euch nur sagen er kommt doch mal ab und
zu in die schweiz nützt die gelegenheit
zu einem kleinen abstecher vielleicht
auch mal ein historiker seminar viele
hier über die reine und russland der
kontakt ist eine
richtige zeit ist noch die neue
versicherung die deutschen wüssten ja
schon wie es geht nein kommt in die
schweiz wir haben die maßnahmen danke
erbittertem widerstand natürlich der
medien und auch in der direkten
demokratie das vielleicht auch der
letzte punkt das merkt man natürlich
dass in der schweiz aufgrund unseres
institutionellen modells der widerstand
gegen die maßnahmen viel größer war
warum hat man schon vor einem monat
gesagt die pandemie ist vorbei in
deutschland können sie auch nur alle
vier jahre wählen dazwischen hat die
regierung größere freiheiten und deshalb
haben sie jetzt auch ein bisschen
größere mühelos zu lassen denn macht ist
natürlich auch verführerisch macht führt
dazu dass sie die politiker nicht
loslassen aber diese sendung hat sich
auch große verdienste erworben hier ein
bisschen kritisch dagegen zu halten und
wenn es dann einen frieden gibt damit
der nähmaschine möglicherweise noch den
freiheits oder der bild -zeitung
umgehängt bekommen weil ja maßgeblich
war eindeutig besser aber treffen
persönlich gar nicht ja also das
machtbewusstsein bei der fdp der
saturierten fdp minister das leuchtet
mir nicht ein das macht bewusst denn an
der liberalen partei müsste doch gerade
die chance wittern sich jetzt zu
positionieren denn sonst prophezeit ist
die fdp bei der nächsten bundestagswahl
wieder wer weiß wie viel weiter unten
wir erinnern uns vor zwei wochen wenn
sie draußen und wenn die ich glaub die
wähler der fdp werden sich sehr genau
anschauen was da jetzt passiert werden
sich noch merken deswegen denke ich also
machtinstinkt würde doch eher nahe
liegen dass man die chance ergreift es
gibt gar keine bessere chance für
profilierung für eine liberale partei
mit regierungsbeteiligung ist jetzt zu
sagen wir
wir tragen keine maßnahmen mit die nicht
durch eine akute notlage
gerechtfertigt sind wir halten uns
sozusagen an sich an die vorgaben
unseres grundgesetzes hat ja gar nichts
vorschreiben einfach nur standards so
weiter dann schon sage ich also ich
teile die kritik in der sache total aber
zum stichwort grundgesetz würde ich
jetzt schon mal sagen auch aus der
perspektive ist dafür der für das
verfassungsrecht zuständig ist und mit
einem juristen seminar als gegen punkte
drohen
so wie sie von gelernten glases
maßnahmen sind jetzt nicht zwingend
verfassungswidrig rechtlich sind sie
machbar aber und da will ich einstimmen
in die kritik die denke ist natürlich
schon eine falsche zu sagen mannschaft
freiheitsbeschränkungen auf vorrat es
gibt für diese einer aus meiner sicht
auch keinen grund sondern wer über die
beschränkung von freiheitsrechten
entscheidet ist denn da für demokratisch
legitimierte gesetzgeber die perfekt
machen kann jederzeit wieder
zusammenkommen und deswegen finde ich
auch wir brauchen jetzt nicht dieses
breite instrumentarium sondern der
bundestag muss als selbstbewusstes
parlament sagen wir geben hier keine
vorratsbeschlüsse dafür dass die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz dann für
sich entscheiden und ich will auch eine
begrifflichkeit von dieser basis
maßnahmen das klingt ja so dass der
staat überhaupt ein bisschen was könne
kontakt beschränkung masten pflicht das
sind ja alles krasse freiheit beschränkt
wir haben uns zwar dran gewöhnt und ich
finde sie sind ja auch an vielen stellen
gerechtfertigt aber da verliert der
staat in gewisser weise auch maß und
mitte wenn man das als basis maßnahmen
ihr geht damit will man gar nicht wissen
dass dann hatte man sich unter vorlage
und zwar ich fand es sehr großartig ihr
seid ja die grünen die wir sind nicht
die
sind ja so erst gemeinsam also die vier
jugendorganisation von den grünen der
cdu das sagen und der fdp zusammen auf
die straße gegangen weiß was ich
vermisse philipp wann sind denn meine
jungs politiker auf die straße werden
damit die kinder in der schule keine
masken tragen müssen und ich glaube
schon dass wenn in der politik mal die
stimmen dafür lauter werden würde gibt
jetzt auch gar nicht daran erinnern
dafür wären ehrlich gesagt es ist auch
unter eltern ganz umstritten es gibt
unter eltern wirklich auch viele die die
noko wird strategie fahren und die den
wieder am liebsten wäre es hätte alles
so ich glaube das ist nicht so einfach
durchzusetzen aus vorsicht vor diesem
diskurs glaube wenn man sich die meinung
hätten können nur darf auf die strafen
können dafür auf die straße gehen oder
sie können es auch einfach im bundestag
sagen sie muss ja auch nicht so also
können sie ja auch ich muss aber sagen
dass masken thema auch in den schulen es
ist natürlich immer blöd wenn am ende
nur die schüler mit maske dasitzen und
in den clubs sitzen alle in der disco
und feiern wir wissen ja auch ohne maus
so genau was wir und so wir sind
arbeiten nämlich an alle geimpft so nah
und im kita ist beispielsweise ist das
nicht der fall wird erst am 5 also ich
bin ja heute nach deutschland geflogen
im flughafen da haben alle masken und
diese maßnahme aber es gibt doch jetzt
keinerlei grundlage für irgendeine
maßnahme man wir haben diese omikron
variante die wirksame ist dass eine
impfung also man muss die leute ja dann
müssten wir die leute ermutigen dass sie
sich jetzt wieder ins leben stürzen und
das meine ich eben das ist schon dass
das macht die droge macht die politik
leidet an einer überdosis macht und sie
kommen jetzt von dieser droge nicht mehr
weg denn epidemiologisch wissenschaften
ich was man uns jetzt jahrelang oder
monatelang eingetrichtert hat auch
nichts mehr mit wissenschaft zu tun dass
man masken tragen muss hat sich noch nie
was mit wissenschaft zu tun dass man in
den schulen den kindern was genannt so
ich habe dass er bei uns gesehen
meine und da muss man natürlich dann
schon schauen also da muss dann auch die
bürgerliche politik in deutschland muss
das natürlich aufarbeiten was die
regierung gemacht hat und warum man das
gemacht hat das ist also da braucht man
einen rechenschaftsbericht das muss man
haarklein analysieren weil hier sind
grenzen überschritten worden ist in
freiheitsrechte außer kraft gesetzt
wurden und eben die leute die politik
hat longo wied di lasso nicht los sie
ziehen sie einfach durch und ich teile
die enttäuschung auch aus schweizer
sicht über die fdp da bin ich froh bei
ihnen herr rosenfeld aber auch die cdu
tschuldigung naja ich hab ich auch
richtigen regen wesentlicher grafen wo
dafür versteckt genehm ist doch mal
sagen so jetzt ist fertig ihr seid der
opposition ich will zur ehrenrettung der
fdp nur sagen wir sind die einzigen die
uns in der regierung vom sozialismus
beschützen
das ist hier eine cdu fdp und ich wir
hätten aber immer die cdu mannschaft die
hosen liebe fehlt
eine klare haltung wir haben eine klare
haltung auch adressiert zu diesem thema
basismaßnahmen und ich finde das kann
man jetzt nicht auf vorhalt entscheiden
sondern da muss das parlament gefragt
werden und am ende klar parlament
debattieren im plenum das ist für
manchen lästig dass es aber die
spielregeln der demokratie dass man über
freiheitsbeschränkungen immer wieder neu
entscheidet und ich solche
vorratsbeschlüsse die haben ja gerade
schon über kinder gesprochen und
patricia plat hier hat uns heute auch
ein thema mitgebracht was die kinder in
diesem land betrifft ja ganz genau meine
these ist nämlich deutschland ist
ziemlich kinderfeindlich und dass das
zeigt sich gar nicht erst seit der
pandemie das zeigt sich schon viel
früher das zeigt sich in absoluten
kleinigkeiten waren sie schon mal mit
kindern im restaurant kann sie da
willkommen ich muss mal gefreut dass sie
kommen weiß es gibt es eigentlich nur
augen rollen und so ist es für eltern
und sie wissen nicht so richtig sind wir
hier willkommen sollen wir wieder raus
hier in berlin gibt es cafés haben
poller damit er bloß kein kinderwagen
reinkommt jetzt habe ich dieses video
gesehen es geht gerade auf instagram
durch die decke mehrere zehntausend
menschen haben sich das angeschaut und
ich zeige ihnen einmal
ich könnte jedes mal kotzen wenn ich ins
restaurant einkommen und sowieso ein
kind am ipad ist jedes mal wenn ich das
im strahl kurz mal ist das schlimmste
was so einem kinder gehen an tun kannst
wirklich dieser kleine kasten da kann
ich jede maus club wenn man sagt kinder
müssten wären computern lernen bullshit
da alles klar
wissen sie was ich finde es auch nicht
so wahnsinnig toll wenn meine kinder vom
ipad setzen aber ich will sie einmal
mitnehmen in die situation die eltern
ins restaurant gehen wenn kommt da ein
mann kommt mit den kindern alle drehen
die augen schon nach oben und hoffen
dass man sich nicht in den besitz und
dann hofft man natürlich so sehr dass
die kinder sich benehmen ruhig sind oder
mein lieblingswort funktionieren und das
tun sie dann natürlich überhaupt gar
nicht das freut natürlich alles nach
hinten los eltern kriegen schweißperlen
auf der stirn und hoffen nur dass die
nudeln main konnten dann kommen die
nudeln endlich die kinder sind überall
die blicke werden immer böser und dann
schneller sein und so geht's ja es ist
zum kotzen wenn die kinder vor so einem
ding setzen aber manchmal eltern gar
keine andere wahl weil wir es nicht
geschafft haben eine kleinigkeit einen
normalen restaurantbesuche für eltern in
irgendeiner art und weise angenehm zu
machen und ich möchte jetzt hier auch
diese frage mal einen tisch tragen ich
bin sehr gespannt wer von denen die hier
mit an unserer diskussion stars sitzen
schon mal richtig mit den augen gerollt
haben im flieger oder im restaurant wenn
eine familie mit kleinen vielleicht auch
richtig schön klärenden kindern rein kam
sicherlich obwohl ich selber
achtjährigen sohn habe und diese ganzen
die tester auch gemacht habe aber sobald
das kind dann aus diesem alter rassismus
schreibt findet man sich dann plötzlich
selber eine situation wieder wo man dann
merkt dass man genervt ist das will ich
ganz leugnen
was die situation im restaurant angeht
würde ich immer eher so eine nintendo
switch empfehlen
[Gelächter]
aber grundsätzlich würde ich dieser
diagnose schon absolut zustimmen das was
du sicherlich besonders auch in der
deutschen gesellschaft ente
kinderfeindlichkeit gibt die spürt man
ja überhaupt nicht wenn man weiß ich
nicht lieferanten und
das hat sich jetzt auch noch mal auf
eine ganz unangenehme art und weise
kondensiert man gar nicht mehr richtig
war sie momentan jemals wieder
rauskommen will also was da eigentlich
in den letzten zwei jahren passiert ist
ist tatsächlich finde ich wirklich
historisch schlimmer und ich finde jetzt
in einer besonders verfahrenen situation
weil die kinder die ganze zeiten und
gegenstand von gewissermaßen
verbitterten kultur kämpfen sind also es
gab lange gar kein bewusstsein dafür wie
kinder unter der pandemie unter den
pandemie maßnahmen auch gelitten haben
vor allem der schule jetzt wird diese
ganze bewegung leid laut das vorher
schon davon gesprochen die alle sagen oh
gott unsere kinder werden in der schule
durchseucht wir müssen jetzt vor dem
schwimmen virus schützen wir dürfen die
schulen nicht wieder aufmachen aufmachen
es ist eine völlig verfahrene situation
wassermassen die kinder zwischen die
fronten von von absoluten ideologischen
konflikt geraten sind und wo es ja weiß
ich nicht wo man sich wirklich erst mal
ganz neu sortieren muss um wirklich zu
schauen was ist da eigentlich alles
schief gelaufen und wie kann man da
wirklich was an der situation verbessern
ich finde die panini hat das so
unfassbar entblößt ich finde nur dieses
kleine beispiel dass ich gewählt hat
zeigt dass es teilweise so leicht wäre
auch dinge zu ändern also ich sitz ja
auch nicht im restaurant und freue mich
über jeden nachbartisch also da sitzt
vielleicht jemand der cloud oder dann
sitzt jemand der redet laut oder oder
mensch um die masken auf dem tisch
so widerlich wie menschen also ich hab
wirklich ich habe übrigens würde ich
sagen ich freue mich mit den augen bei
kindern aber masten wenn menschen dann
am nämlich diese maske am besten noch
haben oder um den hals tragen während
man ist oder auf dem tisch liegen haben
das regt mich fürchterlich auf und da
habe ich zum beispiel habe ich eine ganz
kurze in zündschnur nur dann kann ich
gar nicht aber wie reagiert ihr denn
alle also philipp amt ich meine
nee also wie vor meinen augen gereizt
innerlich war innerlich viel
aber es gehört ja zur wahrheit ich
glaube da geht es eltern sowie
politikern die fußball bundestrainer
jeder der dann als dritter auf die
situation guckt sagt dann wahrscheinlich
ganz leicht das muss er jetzt nicht sein
das kind da noch kein ipad im restaurant
verbauen den vater ist man eben ohne
kinder
mit tipps zurückhaltend als frommer
wunsch für die eigenen kinder irgendwann
mal mitnehmen dass sie auch nicht mit
dem ipad im restaurant
ob die der lsw aber zur wahrheit gehört
natürlich glauben machte sich der oft
ein bisschen leichter und das zeigt ja
auch glaube ich dieses video man fragt
sich so ein bisschen ist die empörung zu
recht sie zu ungarn ist es eigentlich
ist eine diskussion die man aus
vielerlei sicht sehen kann ich glaube
man muss einfach da müssen wir auch in
der politik glaube ich einen klaren
blick dafür auch haben daheim an
die hand auch das wäre ganz kritisch
aber zum thema kinder das finde ich ganz
gut hat einer meiner amtsvorgänger aus
mecklenburg vorpommern der hat nie die
große bekanntheit gehabt hat aber meine
gute rede im bundestag gehalten wo er
gesagt hat kinderlärm ist zukunftsmusik
finde ich ganz gut das ist irgendwie so
unpolitisch glaube ich in sound den man
sich auch ein bisschen durcheinander in
deutschland begleitet ja das stimmt hier
sollte man du gleich ein sieg und der
holländer habe ich wieder spricht sich
an ramona schweiz ist natürlich eine
ganz ganz ernsthafte frage stellen um
mit dem wir jetzt da konfrontierte die
kinder und die frage ist ja was ist
schlimmer was ist die schlechtere
variante wenn du kinder hast die in
einem restaurant oder auf besuch
herumrennen alles herunterreißen und
dann lässt man die gewähren oder
herumschreien ist das besser oder
schlechter als wenn sie ruhig hingehört
im ipad sitzen ich war die frage ist
nämlich wirklich sehr ähneln die sie
bringen nämlich was ist die
verantwortung der eltern und ich war die
wichtigste verantwortung nicht aber auch
vier kinder um ein kleinster der ist
zweijährig der kommt jeden morgen um 23
uhr morgens und der wille qualität times
mit bild archiv und da sehe ich mich
manchmal nach dem ipad aber der mit
ähnlicher weise
im büro ist das etwas ganz wichtiges
weil ich oft schon gesehen habe kinder
die eltern die finden das ganz toll wenn
ihre kinder alle ein riesentheater
veranstaltungen in den restaurants alle
verringern sollte sind auch kinder und
so und ich glaube da haben die eltern
eine ganz wichtige verantwortung die
kinder doch so zu erziehen dass sie in
der gesellschaft
sicher einfügen können das ist nämlich
auch für später wichtig mit langes und
dass der kleine öko terroristen hat
lothar huber stichwort unsere wenn ich
mit einer stand vorbei danke dessen
zugeschaut haben und bis morgen abend
dann sehen wir uns wieder chips haben
sie noch einen schönen abend bis morgen